في المانيا اضراب شامل هو الاول من نوعه
منذ سبعينيات القرن الماضي ويشمل قطاع
النقل والمطارات الكبرى ويعتبر الاضراب
الحالي من اكبر الاضرابات منذ تسعينيات
القرن الماضي اذ ادى الى خلو المطارات
ومحطات القطارات والحافلات من المسافرين
في جميع انحاء المانيا وهنا تطالب
النقابات بزياده الاجور في قطاع النقل
الذي يعاني اصلا من ارتفاع مستويات التضخم
وصل الارتفاع الكبير في اسعار الطاقه في
اوروبا رئيس نقابه فردي العماليه اعتبر
الاضراب الكبير مساله حياه او موت للالاف
من الاشخاص الذين يكافحون من اجل اجور
اعلى في ظل ارتفاع معدلات التضخم ومن
المقرر ان يلتقي ممثلون نقابات العماليه
مع مسؤولين محليين في جوله ثالثه من
المفاوضات في ظل طبعا استمرار الخلافات
بين الجانبين بينما لا يستبعد مراقبون
التوصل لاتفاق خلال الايام المقبله
وتتفاوض النقابه طبعا بالنيابه عن اكثر من
مليونير موظف وعامل في القطاع العام
وتطالب بزياده وقدرها
10.5% من الاجور المقدار 500 يورو على
الاقل
[موسيقى]